Film Courage: When did you know you
were going to be a writer, Glenn?
Glenn Gers, Screenwriter: I was really little I
was like nine or ten years old I actually at first
I wanted to be a fictional character. I distinctly
remember wanting to be James Bond or The Hardy
Boys or Sherlock Holmes. It was mostly detectives
and spies and at some point around 10 or 11 years
old I it occurred to me that there were people
who wrote those people that I wanted to be and
that life I wanted to live and I sort of shifted
an inch over but I’ve never really stopped wanting
to be fictional. That's how writing is for me,
it's just an attempt to be fictional at all times.
Film Courage: How did you discover
that oh wait there are authors here?
Glenn: There was a magazine called show
magazine at the back in the 1960s and
there was an interview with Ian Fleming who wrote
James Bond and he wrote an article about how he
wrote James Bond and it blew my mind because
there was this person saying how you could
create this world with these people in it and
I was like that's what I want to be and then
Harriet The Spy was a huge influence on me
she wanted to be a writer and she she explored
the world around her and I was like that's
that's what the job I want that's the life
did your parents try to talk you out of it or
were they encouraging no no my parents were very
supportive I was very lucky in that way they were
scared they were nervous but it wasn't like this
was an outrageous thing to do it was just we hope
that you can survive oh and and there were times
when that was in question they helped me out
financially a lot especially in the many years
after college when I was not making any money i've
been very lucky that way I had a lot of support
can you explain how anxiety
almost ruined your writing career
it almost stopped it from starting I was
a terribly terribly anxious young person
still I'm very anxious I just actually writing has
become sort of the way I counter anxiety it's one
of the few things that's totally within my control
and control is what helped having the feeling of
having something in your control is what helps
anxiety so being able to go into a fictional world
or create a world or follow a story in your mind
was one of the few things that would prevent
me from feeling anxious and yet when I tried to
write them down I was always very self-critical
it always seemed more complicated than just making
it up in your head to actually get it down on
on paper was was very difficult and so I
started wanting to write when I was 10 or 11
and I would write outlines or plans for things and
write beginnings of things but I wouldn't be able
to actually finish them and I could not figure
out why the answer was anxiety the answer was not
having a process and and it took about 10 15 years
of struggling with that and having writer's block
and and being talented I mean I could think of
this stuff I would write good stuff when I wrote
but I would write very very rarely and it would
be very upsetting and one of the things I had
to teach myself which is what I now try to teach
others is the importance of having a reassuring
process a routine a very mechanical way of
doing the work so that there's no anxiety
involved because it's just like if you were
a musician you would practice your instrument
regardless of quality regardless of of importance
you just run your finger over the keys over and
over and over again and if you do that as a writer
if you push yourself to just write even if it's
bad if you push yourself to just get used to the
experience of stopping and starting and starting
and stopping every day for days and days and
days eventually it becomes so comforting and
familiar that you can actually do the creative
stuff the creative stuff comes after the process
a lot of this actually reminded me I eventually
ran into stanislavski's writing about actors
and I recognize that it's the same thing
I actually think of it as method writing
because the idea of an actor having to go
out on a stage and be able to summon up an
emotion on cue every night when it was in
theater and you had to do it every night
was a struggle that anyone would have a problem
doing and so the stanislavski tried to work out
a process a method by which you can create a
a very mysterious thing called emotion on cue
even if it's not yours even if you don't feel
it and that's essentially what a writer does
there's just nobody looking but you have to sit
down at your desk and somehow transport yourself
into a fictional world into a created place
with people who are not you and you have to
feel these feelings and imagine this stuff that
has to come out of you from you know not where
people don't know where creativity comes from you
know when you get it you know when it's happening
but you don't know how it happens and you can't so
what you can know is if I create this ritual this
routine by which I'm going to always open the same
type of notebook or I'm going to have the same
format I'm working in and I'm going to understand
the mechanics of writing the idea of character
and story and people taking action and if
you get all those things and you apply them
to whatever you're writing over and over you'll
eventually become so comfortable with the process
that you'll become creative and after
many many years where I would just panic
every time I had to write now I actually find that
writing is the thing that keeps me from panicking
about life and that I'll find myself every
day if I don't write I get nervous but
if I do write or if I if I trust the process
it will absolutely take away the anxiety I can
you can't guarantee much about the arts but
I can guarantee that practice and exposure to
the process and creating a ritual is almost
always guaranteed to make your art better
and so it sounds like that definitely didn't come
right away from you you it took years because you
you were enrolled in school and then you left I
was I was very lucky I got into yale university on
there was a freak moment when they were accepting
very creative people without great grades it was
in the mid-1970s and the world was in turmoil
and things were not as stressed as they are now I
guess all I know is I was good at english but not
much else and I applied to a bunch of schools and
I got into yale and so I went I didn't actually
even want to go to college I just wanted to be
a writer and I thought this is just a waste of my
time but I got in I can't not go and I went and it
was a cool experience but by the end of the first
year I was struggling with my writing and I blamed
college I now know what I just told you which
is that I had been struggling with my writing
before college and I was going to struggle with
it after college but for that moment I was like ah
if I only didn't have this college thing I would
be able to write which is crazy because like I had
you know four classes and I didn't have that much
to do but dropped out in my the beginning of my
sophomore year and I called my parents I actually
said to them would you take the money you're
paying college and just give it to me to pay for
an apartment so I can be a writer and they said no
oh okay they're not insane they're supportive
but not crazy okay and they said but you know
if you want to come home come home so
I came home and I lived in the basement
and I just tried to write and all the
problems I had that I blamed on college
they were still there when college wasn't and
I was I tried everything it would be like oh
if I only had this music to play then I would
be able to write and I would go out and buy a
record and then oh if I only read this book
I would be prepared to write this book and
a whole year went by like that I just like
terribly stressed and never getting anything done
and and trying every day and feeling terrified
because I screwed up college and now I had nothing
and one day I was trying to
write a play and I ended up
writing the opening of a movie version of
the play I was reading william goldman's
scripts and and novels and william goldman
is such an amazing and influential writer
and his style of screenwriting is so catchy
that I just thought I can't write this play
but I can imagine the movie version of the play
I'll write it in his style so I wrote about six
or seven pages of the opening and it was the
first thing I had written in about a year
and it it sort of broke open the gates to
the concept of this what I was saying about
having a process just learning how to
understand who the characters are and
what the scene they're in is and if you learn to
think in scenes then you just write that one scene
so that was that I got six pages written in a year
and I said I better go back to college because I
need something to cover the next three years while
I try and figure out how to get over this I went
back to college this is a terribly long story
okay what did you live in I lived in new york
oh okay and I so it wasn't far from new haven and
I they they they took me back with some caveats
and then I had a couple of years when I was going
to college and trying to overcome this writing
problem which I was working towards but honestly
it wasn't until after that so we're talking now
years and years later I'm still having a hard
time with getting all the creativity out and
I was trying to write a novel and I was working
as an office temp I worked as an office temp for
12 years on and off after college before
I start to make a living as a writer
and during the many years of office tempting I
was writing at different people's desks every day
I would have a new job every day sometimes and I
would lug my writing around in a little briefcase
and I had to learn how to write in the spaces
when no one was bothering me at temp jobs so
like someone would say go xerox something at xerox
and i'd have like half an hour nothing to do and
that's when I could write and so that was like the
antithesis of a good writing space you know I'm in
a public office and I have a little notebook and
I learned that if you just think about the scene
you're in you just think about the moment that
this character is trying to accomplish this
one thing that they are doing because people only
do one thing at a time characters are only doing
one thing at a time so you only need to write that
one thing and so I specifically remember there was
a scene of a character the story was that he
had sublet his apartment to a serial killer
he was a wannabe screenwriter and he just
discovered a body in his apartment and he
goes to call the police this is back in the 80s so
it was he had to go to the pay phone on the corner
and I had to describe what it's like to run to
a pay phone in the corner in the rain and tell
the police that you'd sublet your apartment to a
serial killer and I just tried to imagine what it
was like for a struggling screenwriter and I had I
had at the time holes in my shoes because they had
worn through and i'd put cardboard in them so I
described what it was like when the rainwater came
through the hole in your shoe and what it was like
to try and explain to the police why you would
sublet your apartment to a serial killer I had not
done that part but I was in the moment and that's
really what it's about thinking about the scene
and being in the moment and understanding what a
character is trying to accomplish and why there's
an obstacle to that in this case the obstacle was
shame the fact that he was a little ashamed
that he had gotten himself into the position
and so that's it character objective obstacle
scene there's somebody who wants something
and they're trying to do it but there's something
in their way if you have that then you can always
find that just that little piece then you can
write and I remember writing the scene and going
wow I did it the thing that was here is down there
and I started to learn to practice that process
the process of thinking in scenes of understanding
that you're not writing the whole story
you're just in this moment with this character
and that was the beginning of teaching myself
that process and it still took a long time but
that's that's what I learned that's how I survived
and that's what I'm trying to tell people now and
do you think by the fact that you had just a quick
amount of time half hour and you knew too probably
people in the office might be watching or whatever
that you there were no excuses well I need to
organize this and dust this before I start going
oh yeah when I was in high school and I was like
I'm going to be a writer but I can only write if
I have nothing else to do all day I mean even
when you're a full-time professional writer you
have other things to do all day you never get
a whole day free so yeah I had this irrational
sense that I had to have the right kind of music
and the right typewriter which actually did make a
difference and and now I was in the exact opposite
of that I was at a different office every week and
god knows somebody could come up to me at any
moment and ask me to do something that I hated
and and that's when I began to recognize
that all my insistence on what I thought
was the writer's process was actually making
it harder and that when I started to recognize
that if you think in scenes and if you understand
what the character wants and if you know all of
that stuff that method acting for writers you
can you can do it anywhere anytime which was
good because I had to do it anywhere at any time
and that's really actually a very valuable thing
for anyone who wants to be a professional now
because most professionals are going to be working
on shows not movies they're not going to be
writing at home and sending it in they're going
to be in a room and you got to be able to deal
with people coming around you and with orders
being given and things being changed and the more
that you can get a strong process a sense that
somebody says to you a guy's on a bus and he's
got a duck in his bag go and you have to write
a scene the more that you can teach yourself that
skill that tool of being able to imagine a scene
understanding that someone needs to do something
and then getting used to the flow of just putting
something down imagining it and grabbing it
in in a form that you can get onto a paper
that's the most valuable skill I think I if you
ask any showrunner I think they're going to say
I really want someone that I can say this weird
thing just was demanded of us you need to do it go
and they come back next you know in an hour
with a scene that's really valuable and that's
what office temping taught me so everyone
should go out there and become office steps
and would you was there like a temporary agency
that you would check in with and they would give
you an assignment yeah it was called payson people
they're long gone but i'd say interesting it was
it was sweet there was a very small office
it wasn't one of the big ones and but they
had they would every week I would call in and say
where am I working this week and sometimes it was
like thursday or at this place friday or at this
place and sometimes it's like you're not working
this week but for much of 10 years that's what
I did did anyone pressure you to or you know did
they offer you a full-time job because sometimes
if you're a temp they go I like that guy yeah
you know eventually there was at about the nine
year mark I did actually take one of the jobs
as a full-time job the people were lovely and
they knew I was a writer and I didn't I was like
don't if you can't handle the fact that I'm going
to be writing every free minute you know don't
don't hire me but we worked it out and I so I
worked for because the benefits helped a lot
and also actually at that time I was trying to
learn how to do diy filmmaking and a small eight
millimeter video had just started and I had I had
gotten some eight millimeter video equipment I
wanted to make features on eight millimeter radio
as practice just I wanna make a practice movie
and I thought like in theater you do a workshop
you don't just send the play out into the world
you do practice workshops and I thought why
don't we do that for movies so I used my office
after hours I got permission to to shoot in the
office I did a whole corporate espionage drama
about the snack industry oh wow yeah a
lot of insider yeah there's a yeah it's
a brutal a throw yeah and were you riding
on the subway were you taking the subway
I was writing on stuff I wasn't writing on
the subway I was I was absorbing the world
in so many ways sure through every orifice oh
yeah but but no I i I tended to write either at
desks or at home in the morning before like
I wake up at like four and write for an hour
before getting ready to go and did anyone
question you and say well what are you doing
with this note what is this notebook that you're
oh yeah well everyone is like oh he's a writer
yeah everyone knew that and there wasn't
a harry at the spy thing where it's like
what are you writing about us but there
was there was a sense of like he's not
really at the time was called a secretary which
I was yeah no people understood that I was
trying to get out of what I was doing and to be
something else and that was generally looked well
upon people people didn't give me a hard time can
you talk more about the fears you had and how did
you know they weren't really fears when it came to
your writing especially when you were starting out
that's interesting because really I believe they
were fears I think that the things that people are
afraid of in writing they should be afraid of you
know you should and if if you're expecting to make
a living as a writer and you're afraid that you
won't that's a very legitimate fear because the
odds are you won't and in fact I think one of the
most important things that I would advise is plan
for the thing you fear if you're really afraid
that you won't make a living as a writer and you
want to be a writer start to plan for how you're
going to be a writer when you don't make a living
at it because I ran into that often even after I
was a professional writer because even when you're
a professional in the union a highly paid writer
it can dry up it can go away things can change
and the important thing that you want to do is
think first of all would I stop writing if I
couldn't make a living at it if so I don't know
that you're going to be a very happy and be a
writer because you you need to be able to want
to do it no matter what and then okay so I will
be a writer and work early in the morning
before my job as a pharmacist or I will
be a writer and be as I was an office temp
for 12 years or I will be a writer and live
with my family for the rest of my life whatever
it is you know there's no right or wrong way to
do this there's no actual path and so you've
got to figure out what makes sense for you and
one of the most important things about that is to
recognize what you're afraid of and try and plan
for the reality of it if it's going it could
happen you know and and I think that that
actually is what helps a lot is to say well all
right if I don't make it in hollywood would I
still keep writing and the answer should be
yes it may not be I keep writing scripts or
maybe I'll write scripts for podcasts that I
can produce myself or I'll write for theater
or I'll make graphic novels whatever it's going
to be face the fear and be realistic about it
that that was actually what got me through that
that big fear am I going to be able to do this
there are so many fears to being an artist
aren't there because I was just thinking
that's one but then there's the fear of am I any
good maybe I'm not good enough and once again the
answer has to be well you're going to be as good
as you're going to be I mean being afraid of it is
not going to make you better so you might as well
just be how you are and see where that lands you
you can't actually change many things there's a
lot of things that make it easier or harder for
each of us and every one of us is different
and for me the fear of you know will this
be accepted will this be liked at a certain point
it's probably better to look at that fear and say
would I keep writing this
even if everyone hated it
and if you can find something that you would write
then that's probably the thing you should write
find a way to do the thing that you do no matter
what that's that the because the rest of the fears
for most of us like nobody's going to cut
your hands off if you write badly you know
I mean except in certain places probably right but
hopefully for those of us who are not living there
you know it's these are nice problems to
have and artists should take a deep breath
and recognize that you know the the worst thing
that could happen is you don't make a fortune
oh gee you know if you write operas or poems you
would never even occur to you screenwriters have
this weird idea that they're supposed to be rich
and famous that is not actually an artist's lot
most 99.9 of screenwriters are not rich and famous
99 of working screenwriters are not even rich you
know it's it's and certainly in the the scale of
what we think of as that percentage of of that's
what a screenwriter is most screenwriters don't
get to choose what they work on and and honestly
what you're doing is balancing you're saying I
want to get paid for writing but I also want to
write what's in my head well you're not going to
get to do both of those most of the time if you
write what's in your like I wrote I was a working
screenwriter for 25 years and non-stop great jobs
exciting I almost was never writing a project
that I conceived of I was being hired by people
who wanted my talents and my skills for their
project and that was paying the rent and then you
know the best day job you'll ever have and some
of the most wonderful experiences i've ever had
but I was not writing what I could imagine so I
had to do that on the side almost none of those
projects went anywhere people would read them
and say wow that's great we can't make that
so you know that's success that's you know is
that is that the picture that you all have out
there of your success no everyone has the success
picture of those two or three writers that we see
interviewed who are like oh yeah well I decided I
was going to do this project and I called them up
and I told them I was doing it and they gave
me a million dollars and I went and wrote it
that's just not how that's you know that's
winning the lottery that's getting hit by
lightning being born into the royal family you
know if if you're lucky enough that that happens
great but most of us should plan for the thing
we fear and were your fears greater at that time
to make a living as a writer or would you even get
another temp job because you know with the damping
sometimes you don't know if you're going to be
working from week to week or hi we don't need you
anymore and you're like okay did I do something
you know and which fear was greater at that time
that's actually a great question because it brings
up the issue of sustainability and by which I do
not mean you know we recycle our projects I mean
you have to be able to have a sustainable life
to be an artist a creative person of any type and
so you need to be able to separate those and say
I need to deal with the fear of not paying
the rent and not having food and not having
a good relationship and all those life
things that are very important they
have nothing to do with your work and your
work should not be making the save on those
you should not be saying I have a crappy
relationship but one day I'm going to be
such a famous writer that they'll love me anyway
that's a bad plan have a good life and then write
have a life that you can live whether or
not you ever become a rich and famous writer
and and if that is a small life good whatever as
long as it's a sustainable life as long as you can
take care of yourself then you can apply yourself
to the process of writing an artist they're an
artistic problem the problems of am I good enough
is this meaningful enough all those things let
alone will it make any money which is not really
entirely an artistic problem is a separate thing
that you do when you have the space and the
health to do it you first have to take care
of yourself you have to have a place to live and a
routine by which you can live fairly reliably and
hopefully with some good mental health take care
of that first don't be in debt don't put off all
the things of your life until you you know oh I'll
take care of that when I'm when I'm successful
no one's ever successful enough to take care of
that that has to come first and then you make
a space for your work and you'll deal with each
artistic problem like what is this scene about or
is this a good idea that I feel like committing a
year to those are artistic problems but they have
nothing to do they shouldn't be how you decide
whether or not you're going to pay your rent
if you get lucky I mean honestly once you
know if you get into the union and you become
a professional writer you're still basically not
going to be asking that question you're going to
be asking how do I get this job that someone else
has done the creative work on and I want to work
on their project because except for a small teeny
number of people who are show runners or people
who are writing features which is a very small
number now you're mostly working on a staff that's
a job it's a job at a corporation a great job but
often a great corporation and it's really cool
but it's not an artistic problem artistic
problems should be solved with artistic things and
life problems should be definitely solved
with life things not with artistic solutions
can you tell us the reasons why
being a screenwriter is impossible
yeah absolutely that actually in many ways I
would advise no one to be a screenwriter it is
by far one of the dumbest arts to try and be
in other than maybe a large scale architecture
the first thing about screenwriting is you're
never getting to finish the work in other
words you get to finish the script but it's not
available to an audience until it's made by other
people so basically you're creating something
in order to give to a bunch of other people
so they'll create another thing and frankly
a different thing the thing that's based in
your script is a production and it will change in
many ways so if you really are like I can totally
picture this movie in my head and that's why I'm
writing it get over it it will never ever be like
that even in the greatest of circumstances where
things are better than you want it will never be
as you imagine but honestly I believe that's
the creative process itself when you imagine a
script it actually comes out differently than you
first imagined it or what you think the process
of transforming anything into a concrete
work out of an abstract thought changes it
and honestly when a reader reads it it's
going to change again because when you say
he wore a red tie they're going to picture
a different red tie that you're picturing
and you have to be able to accept that you
have to be able to accept that the script is a
a piece of a project that you will not have any
control over so that's number one is unless you
really like that process of doing something
for other people to work from it's frustrating
and I know actually a lot of writers get very
irritated at actors and directors which is too bad
because they should be more respectful of the
other arts but they're like they didn't say that
like I thought they should like I know how that
line should go and that's not how it works the
line goes how it goes in their mouth the actor has
to be free to act the way they would act it and if
you're depending on them saying it exactly the way
you imagined it which is frankly not on the page
it's not going to happen so writing screenwriting
is more frustrating than most types of writing but
then not only that among most types of writing
you have less control because you don't own the
copyright to your work if you're a novelist or
a playwright or any other kind of writer you
own your work they can't somebody may put pressure
on you we you know we won't publish it unless you
change it but they actually can't change it if
you write a script and you sell it to a company
for various reasons having to do with the ability
to unionize back in the 30s screenwriters gave
up their right to own their creative work which
means when you hire on to write something they can
fire you and have someone else rewrite it and you
cannot do anything about it and that always sounds
like oh that'll be fine I'll live with that it
hurts everyone gets fired everyone gets rewritten
most of my career was rewriting other people
and I had to be aware of the fact that
somebody out there is grinding their teeth and
cursing my name when if I do well so screenwriting
is just a tough business then you get to the
fact that for most writers now you're going
to be working on a staff of a show which means
it's not even your idea you are one of a bunch
of people contributing ideas and the actual writer
of the show the creator the showrunner is going to
be saying yes to that no to that that line is
good that line is good we'll put them together
you may get creative satisfaction you may
be doing grunt work you may also I mean on
a feature I wrote there was an introductory
scene of a character that I just hated the
way the producers wanted this character to be
introduced they they thought she was cute and I
thought she was reprintable and I kept saying do
you really want her to say that and they're like
yeah we think it's funny and I was like I didn't
have an h I had to write the scene the way they
asked for it or I would be fired or someone else
would be hired to replace or rewrite that scene
that's not what most people picture as being an
artist it's not what most people picture as being
a writer but I can go on the number of reasons
that you shouldn't be a screenwriter are enormous
the reasons that most people want to be
screenwriters are misleading first of all they
think and it's true you are very very highly paid
if you are a working screenwriter in the unions
in the studio system the network system that is
a very small percentage of the people who are
trying to be writers so it's like
saying I want to be a baseball player
and you're imagining I'm going to be major league
most people are not going to be major
league the question is would you stop
playing baseball then and I i can't imagine
I can't imagine saying I want to be an artist
but only if they'll pay me first that's
that's not how generally arts should work
um most people imagine that screenwriters have
a get to people come to the writer because
honestly and this is a problem of the
screenwriting industry you know the everyone who
teaches you know they're all saying like it all
begins with the script the script is so important
and you get all these actors and directors they're
saying like you know and it's true they choose a
good script to work on it's like we couldn't do
this without the script and wannabe screenwriters
are like I'm so important and I promise you
you're not they are going to change your work
they are going to misinterpret your work that's
just part of the job you are providing a beginning
to someone else's creative process and so that's
a hard thing to almost every screenwriter I know
is looking for a creative outlet they're looking
for they're writing novels on the side or plays or
they're painting or whatever and you wouldn't
think that that's what being a successful
screenwriter is but truthfully it is it's a it's
a job it's a glorious job and when it works right
you have these amazing experiences where talented
people take your work and they like your art
and they do stuff and it works and then it goes
out to a big audience and that's a little tiny
slice of the experience the things i've
had made were amazing there are only two
three percent of what I actually worked on most
of what I worked on no one will ever hear of it's
trapped in some company's vault somewhere or in my
drawer because no one bought it and I'm talented
I'm good I'm successful I'm in the union I'm
highly paid and most of what I write is rejected
so yeah be a painter if you can because at least
you get done you have the finished painting
but the flip side of that so that I don't
just discourage the heck out of everybody
the flip side is if you get good at it you learn
certain skills about narrative and character
that are invaluable no matter what else you try
to do creatively if you want to be a director
it's great to know what screenwriting really
is what a scene and a character really are
it's very important to understand how much the
character's motivation the character's goal their
the thing they're trying to do that's crucial and
if you're writing a novel it's just as important
and if you're writing a graphic novel or a
video game whatever it is those basic ideas
about a character wanting something and having a
difficult time getting it that is the center of
any kind of narrative creativity and screenwriting
pushes that harder than most if you can learn it
in screenwriting you can do it anywhere so it's
sort of good to learn to be a screenwriter because
then you've got a skill set if you decide to
work in video games great you're going to be
really really set and when you were temping in new
york city were you attempting to be an author or
it was when you wrote that play and then you saw
it was sort of goldman-esque and you thought let's
do screen no ever since I was like a kid I when
I see something I want to do it like paint I was
painting for a while I was drawing I was I was
writing plays I was trying to direct movies I
was trying to write movies on super 8 silent film
which is means I had to actually learn how to make
silent movies so I like to say I came up in silent
film it was in the 1970s but that was all they had
then if you were going to make if you're a high
school student you want to make a movie they had
eight millimeter home movie cameras I would make
silent movies I tried to write novels because I
love novels plays because I love plays I i have a
dangerous desire to do absolutely anything I see
so no I was I was always doing all of it and
I would sort of shift my focus depending on
what was practical when I was in high school I
got tired of silent movies it was frustrating
to not have any dialogue but high school
they had plays so I started to write plays
high school and college I did plays I got out
of college I was sort of thinking of writing
plays sort of thinking of writing novels
but screenwriting I thought that would pay
for all of them if I could get screenwriting jobs
I could afford to do everything else and then for
12 years I was in office temp and couldn't afford
to do anything except right in my off time but the
theory always was I was going to do it all and
screenwriting was just the most lucrative which
is what everybody thinks and and you know yeah for
the major leagues it's very lucrative for the rest
of us it's not and you should really want to do it
you should love doing it even if no one pays you
I'm wondering if being an office temp for the 12
years that you did it and then doing the writing
on the side or in free time fueled you because if
you'd had a more comfortable job where maybe money
wasn't an option and trying to book work maybe
you would have given up on the screenwriting I
don't think I just personally the way I'm built I
would have I i frequently gave up on jobs rather
than than have them interfere with my what I
thought was my career but I do think that it is
i think that life can really challenge people
trying to be artists that the demands of real life
it's hard it is hard to build a way to get
some time and to feel it's worth it when it's
an abnormal thing to do it's not it most people
aren't doing it and most people's lives don't
require it most people have perfectly fine lives
without writing a novel or a screenplay or doing
you know whatever it is that that an artist wants
to do and and I think it's important to recognize
that you are doing something a little offbeat and
that the most important thing I think you can do
is find a way to comfortably do it in the spaces
you have to do it in whatever they are there
are some people who would rather work for six
months and then take two months off and have the
two months to really work and other people would
rather work an hour a day or every other weekend
or whatever it is you have to you have to look at
yourself you have to see what's productive for you
there's no right or wrong the the novelist seminar
as french mystery novelist thriller novelist he
used to write in intensely short bursts he would
he would plan out a novel and then reportedly he
had a separate house built in his backyard because
he could and he would go to this other house
and he would not talk to his family they would
drop the meals at the front door and for like two
weeks and he wrote short novels he would be like
don't bother me I'm writing and he would go in and
then he would come out with a novel couple weeks
later and then he would live his life and then
next time around he would go back in that's fine
there's other people who you know just like me
office temping a half hour here half an hour there
at other people's desks or like I happen to be a
morning person so I would get up extra early and
work in the morning before work but don't discount
the amount of pressure that real life puts on
your art and I would say the thing to do is adapt
your art to fit that life you know if you like
throwing all these references around the painter
matisse when he got older he couldn't stand
it as easily and paint anymore and he ended up
doing these cutouts he would take paper and cut
out figures and they became gorgeous artwork
called the cutouts there's a book called jazz
and a lot of other work he stopped painting
he couldn't physically paint anymore he shifted
his creativity to something he physically could do
that I think is a really good lesson for everyone
it's like if you can't find the time to do it the
way you think you should like I thought I had to
have an eight-hour free day with a lot of iced tea
and music playing and I found that it was better
to write little tiny slices even just a sentence
or a paragraph if you keep doing a sentence or
a paragraph you will eventually get whatever it
is you need if you wait till you have the whole
day free you may never so that that sort of is
what I think you have to do in the face of that
inevitable conflict and that conflict even happens
when you're a professional writer I would run into
the problem of you know I'm working on a project
a show or a movie or something I had a project
I was dying to do and sometimes i'd have to like
take a break from my writing job so my
job was writing but I had to stop to
do a little indie film that I wanted to do
and so I didn't take work for as long as I
could afford and then I would go back to work
everybody has this problem the important thing
is to really pay attention
to what is productive for you
if that's writing a little bit at a time if that's
writing for short bursts a lot whatever works
I just wasn't sure if however painful
or maybe not so painful some of these
temp jobs were I know some tempting can be
great and some can be probably excruciating
did that fuel you the painful moments to keep
going and also too you're around people that this
is their life they're like lifers at this company
and did you say I don't want to be that guy
yeah yeah well it's sort of I mean to a
certain extent this may that sounds horrible
I generally look around and
say I don't want to be that guy
yeah but what it did do was inform me about all
the parts of life that I didn't know to find out
what it's like to work in this type of place and
that type of I worked in a lot of different places
and in fact the first novel I wrote was about a
wannabe screenwriter who was an office temp so
I guarantee you nothing nothing gets lost on a an
artist who's making his way in the world you got
to be absorbing all of it and writing it down
how did you take control of your creative fate
I think recognizing that the only thing an artist
truly controls is the work itself and that is not
an original thought to me many far better artists
have said it you can't control whether your work
sells whether it is popular even people who have
sold and had hits will find themselves doing
something and it flops that's just predictable
that that will happen so if if they can't control
it if they can't guarantee a hit if they can't
guarantee that people like it how should we
there's no way for anyone to know how things
are going to work out creatively and the way
that you become a happy artist and a productive
artist is to give up worrying about it you say
I am gambling I am rolling the dice on this thing
because I like it because I think it's fun because
I think other people will like it I think that's
a big part of it just saying I am completing this
because I want it complete it has nothing to do
with whether or not someone else will like it you
should at the same time adjust your expectations
if you are writing about a very obscure topic
or in an obscure genre then don't expect a big
budget plan one of the things I had to learn was
if I want to write something weird and offbeat
write it so that I can do it myself with a video
camera and a couple of actors that I get together
learn how to do things diy learn how to you know
work within the limits that you can control
and then you're controlling your creative
fight and then if somebody likes it great if
somebody doesn't like it at least you did it
and you're more likely to do the next
thing better from having completed
work and put it out there and seeing the response
there is nothing like it for an artist to see
people respond to your work and it's one
of the things that screenwriters get to do
very infrequently most working screenwriters most
of their jobs they don't get out to the public
a lot of people do drafts of things that don't get
made now you you do that less because most people
are working on shows when you work on a show they
don't hire you if they're not going to make it but
the experience of doing your work and putting
it in front of an audience starting the work
finishing it and presenting it is the most
important education you can get there is
nothing else that that replaces it so the more you
can do that without asking someone's permission
without waiting until someone says well this will
make me a lot of money so I will invest in it
because people don't people don't put money into
artworks because they like them mostly they put
money into artworks because they think it'll make
them more money so if you do something that's
good but not profitable you won't get to make it
it's better to do something that's good and can be
made really really cheaply and then you can make
it nobody can stop you and if you don't feel like
directing it yourself somebody who does know
how to work low budget will be able to make it
so completing projects is very important
to you is that completing the process
the artistic process is the best
education you can get if you can
write 10 scripts and finish them and ideally at
least get a reading of them but but really the
best thing to do is to shoot them find a way to
get someone to shoot your script make it shorts
whatever that will teach you more than any other
education about screenwriting and if they're bad
so what you know do it in such a way that if you
lose your money it's not the end of the world
how did you get your first
hollywood writing job it was a
fluke a freak occurrence I it was actually a
script that I had written 10 years before it
was my first script and I had gotten an agent
with my first script i'd gotten very lucky I
knew someone who knew someone who showed it to an
agent who picked me up as their client but they
could not get me I there had been a very small
option during the 10 years other than that I was
office temping and administrative assistanting and
doing some development work for indie companies
and I was beginning to think I should
stop I should just because I was actually
planning to become a teacher like maybe a high
school teacher or college teacher if I could
because at least I would have summer vacations
to write it was always what can I do to support
my writing that never stopped but the idea of
becoming a screenwriter stopped because I was like
why keep beating my head against the wall I had
written a bunch of scripts I had an agent I if I
wasn't making it maybe I should quit but the the
first script I had written all of my scripts were
well liked by the people who read them they just
were like this is really good we just can't make
it for a billion reasons there's always a
billion reasons why people can't do things
but a an independent producer who really loved one
of my scripts and I had done some rewrites with
her her name was mae wathridge and she took a job
at tribeca films when it was just starting and she
had to say that she was stopping her independent
career and going to work for tribeca but
she had the opportunity she met with someone
who works with billy crystal who was looking
to work with de niro on what turned out to be
analyzed this eventually after I failed them
but they were looking to work together
and may slipped them my script
and they loved it and they said this this would
work very well and so all of a sudden tribeca
had to pick me up as like oh I guess we'll pick up
his script to take so all of a sudden from being
about to quit I was working with big hollywood
stars and my agent lisa calamaro arranged a
fabulous option and first step deal and all of
a sudden I didn't have to work temp for a year
while I did rewrites on that project which went
so fast downhill and died completely and the they
wanted changes that I didn't know how to make and
I had worked for 10 years learning how to write
what was in my head and I had never learned about
the part of hollywood writing where somebody says
change that that wasn't even on my radar and this
was a long time ago this was in the late 1980s
it just never occurred to me that like someone
would say as they did it was the story was about
a divorcing couple a couple who had gotten
divorced and remarried and divorced again and
over political differences and then the guy
gets involved in espionage and politics and
things and so their divorce the topic of their
divorce becomes the subject of the thriller
and so it was sort of a thriller romantic comedy
and the note was can you take out the divorce
and and it was a completely legitimate note
in one way if you were a flexible hollywood
writer who understood how to rethink things
there are ways to do that and I actually
did that later on another script where I took
out what I considered the center of the story
at the time I had never had that question raised
and I tried so hard I was just like I got to do
this this is my big break and I'm blowing it but
I couldn't I wrote an entire script i've actually
it's the only thing i've ever written that I have
never looked at since it's 30 years now I wrote
it I literally cried through much of the writing
like I was a basket case because I was writing
something that I didn't know what the center was
because for me the center of this story the reason
that everyone was doing something was because of
this couple trying to get back together when you
take that out all you've got is a bunch of people
chasing each other in funny ways but still wasn't
enough to make a scene I wrote a script I have no
idea if it's readable but I got immediately fired
the script went on on the shelf and they hired new
writers and for three years they held on to it and
de niron crystal wisely moved on did analyze
this it was a good choice on their part and at
the end of that three years I got my script
back which was cool because I had been well
paid to let them have it for three years I had
never seen any of the rewrites that were done
after I did it so therefore I was I was allowed
to take everything I had done that was my property
the script I the draft I done for them was
their property because they paid me for it
but the option was over and I just started sending
it out again and I so many people loved it and
got so close to production so many times but what
it taught me was the thing that I thought writing
was about which is you imagine stuff and you get
it down as good as you can and then they pay you
and they make it that's not how the industry
works the industry works that you do all that
stuff and then you start to collaborate with other
people and if you can't do that part if you can't
learn how to use those same creative skills on
demand for things you may not think are great
then they'll find someone who can does that sound
depressing it's not meant to it's meant to it's
meant to say learn the mechanics of the business
so that you can do the job that's that's the
message I hope is being sent there is that there
is the magic of creativity and then there's the
magic of being skilled and knowing how to do the
job no matter what gets thrown at you well I think
it's very important that you bring up that story
because so many ideas of something sound great and
then when you learn what they actually are it's
much much different so that's just fascinating
so it was a year that you had to rewrite that
or that was a year process it was a year of
actually this is it's a funny story so I'll tell
it it's embarrassing I got once I took out the
center of the story I didn't know what the story
would be and I what I do is that when I don't know
what I'm gonna write I just riff I think of
everything I can I brainstorm it could be this
it could be that you know we're on a submarine it
could be the submarines at the bottom of the sea
it could be at the submarine got moved to dry land
what you know everything I can possibly think I
try and get it down on paper there's no such thing
as a bad idea until you've figured out what you're
trying to accomplish with it anything's possible
so I had this huge list of possibilities of this
story and I didn't know which one they wanted and
I was writing for them so I made it into a board
game I actually I was working as an office temp
still so I had access to like a laminating machine
everything and I made a board and it was like
it was like the game of life where you go along
a path but this had like multiple branching paths
for each story and and I tried to lay out all the
different story outlines as a board game with like
cards like if you pick this you go in this tray
it was the most elaborate creative stupid thing
i've ever done and I brought it to billy crystal
I got an appointment I flew to los angeles I gave
it to him and I said this is your story outline
I don't know which one you want and he was really
gracious about it and he was he was great he was
like you know well now I have something to put on
the wall of my office but now we actually have to
write the script after work and he gave me advice
and I worked on it and I did a draft and it was
all fine but that was how little I understood
the job the job by the way is making choices
the point is when I when you lay out the 15
000 possible stories you have to make a choice
everything is a choice every choice has a price
you have to learn to get comfortable with making
choices over and over and over again everything in
creative work is I'm going to choose this and not
that if I choose this that means that I can't have
a happy ending if I choose this it means I can't
talk about communism versus capitalism you know
whatever it is that you want to do it's a choice
and when you make that choice certain things
fall away but other things become stronger
that's the creative process and everyone gets very
afraid of that what if I make the wrong choice
the coolest thing is whatever a writer is to get
comfortable with you know what it's a choice I'm
gonna make it I make it judging I know that the
producers want this well no more choice that's
what I'm doing if you don't know for sure you
change you take the choice and you follow that
path you're gambling maybe it'll work maybe it
won't but it's better to make the choice and be
creative and try and find your solutions than to
try and do both that's the one thing you can't do
got to make a choice and you have to live with
the price when they asked you to take out which
what was the center of the story which is the
couple getting divorced and getting back together
did they didn't tell you what to replace it with
they didn't know when people give you notes they
don't know how to fix it they they just like you
know that seems seems a little wrong or sometimes
they'll know how to fix it but it's not what you
thought would be like you may have a better one
it doesn't matter what matters is that everyone is
going to see things differently and most notes are
this isn't working not do this if they
were to do this then it's like I'll do that
most notes are that's not making sense or
that's too slow or that's too fast but how
you actually solve it that's your task and so
for you that was so new it never occurred to me
it was you know people didn't know that much
about screenwriting in the late 80s early 90s
like it wasn't as much of a thing people
didn't do it as much as they do now now
everybody writes scripts and frankly everyone
should because now everyone can make them
but at the time the experience of being a
professional writer was not very well known
there were only a handful of books and in fact
the first time I came to la I was in my agent
had come out and she had set me up with meetings
and everyone said to me your work is good you
could work here if you moved here but you would be
have to get used to writing things that didn't get
made because at the time that was how development
worked they would develop 50 scripts and make one
which meant 49 writers were writing a script that
was going to be put on a drawer never seen again
and they would be highly paid and they would
be well respected and maybe one of them would
get lucky at one of your scripts would would hit
but you never knew some people had a full career
never getting anything made and that blew my mind
I was like I'm not gonna work a whole year on a
script and not have anyone see it which of course
that's the business that's the job but at the time
I didn't know I had no clue and it took me a while
to process that and to recognize that as a day job
goes pretty cool you learn a lot on it and you get
paid to do the thing you love but it may get put
on the shelf you may never see it again when you
came back to them with other ideas which could be
the center of the story did they not like it
or that was the board game all right this is
the process by which this happens is that the
people who are in charge like if you're a star
or a director and you're supervising writers
you know that you're not a writer and so you
just try to guide them as some are better
than others and it's it's the writer's job
to translate the notes that's part of being a
professional screenwriter is recognizing that
people are going to tell you stuff and you have
to figure out what I believe is you have to figure
out how to turn it into scenes everything about
screenwriting is how to think in scenes if you
can figure out how to make a scene out of an idea
or a desire or whatever it is that somebody says
then you can be a professional writer and so very
often the people in charge will say like honestly
you know I know what end result I want but I
don't know how to get there that's your job
so that was a lot of the notes were like that
and in fact I said I said here's the thing when
it really comes down to it there's a big there's
a binary choice there's a this or that you know
is it a this ending or that ending
and the note was well could it be both
what are you going to do
so eventually I just chose
I actually think this board game is kind of cool
but it was great I wish I don't know if I have a
copy of it I think I gave him the only copy that's
kind of a neat idea I mean if someone had the time
to make the board game that that would be yeah
absolutely no I mean essentially it's create your
own story which is now a completely legitimate
creative project you know you could you can
you know digitally you can make a story that you
could do that with I think it's called a video
game you know and so I just was decades ahead of
my there you go I should have been designing games
do you think things have changed
in hollywood in the past five years
everything has changed in the past five years the
I i personally believe that the changes happening
right now in the entertainment industry are the
biggest since the invention of film back in 1905.
even television coming of television
the coming of of home media
had did not disrupt the the system as much as
the events of the digital technology changes
if you don't mind me getting into that one reason
is because when film began they built up a bunch
of companies in the 1920s in the silent era and
those became the studios and the studios sort
of ran the world for the next decades there
were only a small set of studios and they all
essentially worked in the same field and they all
owned the same theaters that system eventually
incorporated television at first they thought
television would be a threat but then they simply
moved television into their system the studios
ran so many things in television when the digital
revolution happened new companies came in
and instead of buying a studio and saying
keep doing what you're doing they built their own
studios based in entirely different philosophies
and they also built their own distribution
companies because you have to remember the entire
movie industry was is a distribution industry the
movie studios were stu were filmed distributors
they made movies in order to have something
to distribute and the most important thing
to them was distribution because that's where the
people pay money to get the product distribution
is where the money is and with streaming
services they simply opened up a whole new
avenue of distribution that cut the studios out of
the business they took the business away from the
studios and as a result everything changed the the
people running it the philosophies by which they
ran it everything has changed and it's broken up
because the ability to choose what you're watching
the ability to meter how things are watched
all of these things are changing what gets made
as a result everything is sort of
broken up into each company has its own
plans its own philosophy and they are buying and
producing according to what they want to do they
are not doing it according to some unified
industry philosophy of this is what's a hit
furthermore a lot of the technology
companies their principle is
if somebody else is already doing something
we have to do something very different
that it was never like paramount was like oh
you know they're doing this kind of movie so
we'll never do that kind of movie that's not how
that worked they all did the same kind of movie
and so you could just say I'm going to make
a western because everybody's making westerns
now every company every streaming service they're
constantly changing what they want so you can't
plan on ah I can write this and it will be
sold that doesn't happen it has to be a magical
combination of you being good at your writing and
the company having the desire to make that thing
and the only way that you can make that happen is
doing your part of it you do the good work and you
put it out there there's a lot of places out there
hopefully one of them will pick it up that's all
you can do in the face of this new system which
is no longer unified around one set of objectives
do you think people realize that the rules
that they've been living by are no longer there
no I think I i know that's this copyright but
you know wiley coyote when he runs off a cliff
and there's a section there where he's running
in thin air with his legs spinning but he's still
going straight ahead and as far as he's concerned
he's on solid ground I believe that is where we
are which is most of the people who are working
in the industry and most of the people who are
teaching about the industry are operating from
pre-digital philosophies they're like this is
what a story is this is how a thing gets sold and
in fact we're all on thin air and we're gonna drop
we may have a parachute we may get a glider I'm
not saying we're gonna smash I'm just saying
the ground has shifted under our feet and so the
concept of three acts the concept that a movie is
the the story unit these have all changed a story
a story can be in 78 parts a story can be in six
half hours in each of those it's gonna have
a different kind of structure how can you
possibly talk about a universal structure or a a
mythic paradigm that's going to fit all of those
I believe the only thing that fits all of those
is an understanding of the basic tools of writing
a narrative for people to film which means
understanding that you've got characters who
are trying to accomplish something and they they
operate in scenes the one thing I think is true
still of all filmed entertainment is that it works
in scenes and you're going to need to understand
how scenes work every character who enters a
scene has a desire to accomplish something they
are in that scene for their own reason and
if you learn how to write those scenes you
learn how to write a character's objective
and at the end of that scene something has
changed or frustrated them and so they move
into the next scene with that next objective
and when you outline that whole thing into six
half hours or 72 hours or an hour and a half
whatever it is that basic principle of of drama
of storytelling is is what you should get good at
how do you define story and how do you
teach it to clients and students I think the
basic idea of a story is going to be that
you are following a character or characters
it is entirely possible to tell the story of
multiple characters you don't only have to tell
one person's story it's nice you can do it but
it's also possible to tell a story with 11 main
characters it takes a lot of work you have to
follow each main character and follow their story
all the way through the narrative but in fact I
believe any story is really about how a character
trying to accomplish something runs into other
people who either help or harm their intention
it's sort of like isaac newton's theory of the
billiard balls that they they once they get set
in motion they will roll in that same direction
because they're being pushed by a physical force
and I think a character is also doing that they're
they're trying to get somewhere and they're
rolling in a certain direction until either they
hit something or something comes along and knocks
into them and then that changes their direction
but they're still trying to get to that one place
the physics kind of falls apart there because
billiard balls aren't trying to get anywhere
but the idea that things are moving until they
run into something else which is also moving
is sort of how characters work every character
thinks they're the main character if you have
your hero walk into a hotel and try and get a
hotel room that hotel clerk they think they're
the center of the movie because they're the center
of their story and this person coming up to them
is either getting in their way or they're trying
to charm them or whatever it is that they're doing
they're trying to do something and that
interchange is the basic building blocks of
story that's what you call dramatic action someone
trying to accomplish something which mostly
involves interacting with other people sometimes
the action can be I have to take this suitcase
and put it on a train whatever but there'll
still be I have to I have a thing I'm trying
to accomplish and that's what story is I have a
thing I am trying to accomplish I am a character
and I need to get this thing and it will be a more
interesting story if there's something in the way
if I am a character I'm trying to put a suitcase
on a train and I go and I put it on the train and
nothing happens it's a very short boring story
if they're carrying a suitcase and another person
comes and they steal the suitcase it's more of
an interesting story and it's a more interesting
story if that person's got something important
in the suitcase if it's just a suitcase they
could say oh somebody stole it oh well I'll
go get another one not that strong a story
every story is about a character trying to
accomplish something and having an obstacle
and what they do what action they take in
the face of the obstacles is your story the
obstacles don't have to be external the obstacle
can be I'm really afraid of the train station
I need to get this suitcase to my uncle and
he's going to be at the other end of the train
so i've got to get this suitcase onto the train
but I'm terrified of loud noises that's a story
the only obstacle is in there but it's
real so every character is facing obstacles
the obstacles don't have to be physical they
don't have to be another character they just
have to be something that's getting in the
way of them trying to accomplish something
that's important to them can you explain how
questions and choices inform the writing process
writing is a process of questions that like
if I could there's a couple of things that
I wish I could like get tattooed on the
inside of people's eyelids that they knew
think in scenes and writing is a process of
questions it's not a thing you have to fill
out it's not a form that you have to fit into
writing is a question is always a process of
having something it could be just I want to
write a western or I want to talk about how love
hurts or I want to talk about how love saved my
life whatever it is that you start with then you
start to ask questions how am I going to tell this
story am I going to tell it through a character
who gets it or doesn't get it everything is
going to be a choice every question that you ask
if you write down that question how am I
going to tell this story who is the main
character everything is a question and those
questions are who is it about what do they want
why can't they get it what do they do about that
and how does it end I think I skipped one but
oh why doesn't that work right who's it about what
do they want why can't they get it what do they do
about that why doesn't that work how does it end I
did a whole video on this called the six essential
questions so I explained it better there but
those six questions basically will help you write
anything they'll help you write a movie they'll
help you write a video game they'll help you
write a series because that's the essential thing
that you get of how am I going to turn whatever
feeling or idea I have into a story is a person
who is trying to do something to get something
and there's something in the way and then
eventually something will end it either
the end will be I don't get it or I do get it and
whatever they do that they had never tried before
is how it ends because if they had tried it
before it would end before so who's it about
what do they want what do they do why doesn't
that work what do they finally do what is the end
that's storytelling and it can work for three acts
or 27 acts or one act it always works it's it's my
go-to set of questions and then just keep asking
questions who is it about it's about a plumber
where is he from just ask who what why where and
just keep asking why why is he afraid of heights
why you know why does he love this particular
person every time you ask a question and you
get a specific answer you're moving closer
to writing a scene what's the easiest way
for someone to figure out an enjoyable writing
process for themselves the first important thing
about your process is recognizing that it's yours
that there is not a right or wrong way some people
write at night some people write in the day some
people write in short bursts some people write
in long extended verses it's there's no particular
better or worse process the important thing
about a process is it's something that you can do
relatively easily for whatever reason it works for
you and that means you have to spend time paying
attention to yourself trying different things and
seeing which ones work and which ones don't work
and being really honest about that I personally
keep doing that sorry I personally I turned out
to write very well in short bursts I thought
I should do more because when I'm writing in a
short burst it's like holy crap if I could keep
doing this for eight hours i'd be a miracle but
I can't and I would sit there and I would grind
after the burst was running down I would grind
and not only would that be unproductive and begin
to be disheartening but I would start to undo
my good work because when you start to grind
in a bad way you start to doubt you start to
feel bad and you say well I must be feeling bad
because this work is bad which is not necessarily
the case it could be that your process is bad
and so what I would do is I would write something
really good and then I would grind until I was
unhappy and then I would say oh that sucks and
then I would write something over it and destroy
my own good work and it took me a long time to
pay attention to the fact that I do really well
in short bursts and if I stop when I feel myself
starting to lose it and take a break take a walk
do exercises whatever I can then come back and
do another short burst getting myself to sit down
again is rough but that's the thing I had to teach
myself by paying attention to what worked i've
gotten much more productive since I learned my
process it's not for everyone everyone will have
a process that's dependent on their own inner
mechanisms and on their own reality some people
only have free time on weekends some people only
get a little bit of free time you know in the
evenings and so they have to find a way to work
at the time that they are allowed by their life
you have to pay attention to reality and pay
attention to your own inner working and the
best way to find out is to do it and see how it
goes it's always better to try and do some work
and see how it goes you'll never get to the
place where you absolutely know that you can
write and then you start writing it's always a
question of let me try this see what comes out
that's the best test of a process and working
these temp jobs for many other reasons aside from
income and people the study of people helped you
realize that was your preferred story forced me
because I'm stubborn and I would just keep
doing the wrong thing over and over again until
circumstances forced me to work in short bursts
and then I was like wow that actually is better
trying to be open to your process
trying to pay attention to what actually
makes the work good what feels good feeling
good is underrated like the fact that
you know you have to learn to write when you don't
feel good for me having a process that I can say
I always I have five basic documents that I open
like an outline a place where I write notes and
the the text itself and the sort of overview I'm
gonna be doing a video on this actually soon but
that's my personal setup everyone has their own
but but what you need to do is find a thing that
so you always when you open that notebook
you're not thinking about anything except
the contents of the work you know ah this is the
outline the outline is going to be broken into
scenes and the scene lines are going to look
like this and I don't have to think about that
I have to think about what's in the scene that's
the best way to find a process is to get something
that works for you some people will do it on their
phone some people will do it I would advise doing
it in some way that it's written down in some form
digitally on paper on note cards it doesn't matter
what matters is that you get it out of your
head and into the world in some way that you
can set it aside and come back to it set it
aside come back to it because with almost
anything you're going to have to you can't do it
all at once when did you have that aha moment that
I don't have writer's block and my
anxiety was although it was real
it was just that wasn't my style of writing to to
sit at my desk at my parents basement or wherever
and have the perfect music and iced tea that
that actually wasn't working for me it was
it was unfortunately not an aha
moment it was an aha a couple of years
and I think I think that that's a that's
actually sort of a misleading thing that
that our culture has developed from movies is
that that there's a decisive moment and after
it you are always changed in stories that
is a very important thing you need decisive
moments when people are changed but in truth it's
more like a series and I have a couple seasons
where I get a little bit of it then I
fall back into my old ways and then I
have some reward or I think of something new and
it it's a process in which you try to do two steps
forward one step back instead of the other way
around because you're trying to head forward
you do a little forward you fall back you go a
little forward and and the main way it always is
the doing of it just throw something on the
paper even if it's just and I have done this
i've ever seen what I say this is the scene
where he comes home and is you know miserable
and I just took it out of the outline
and I wrote it into the script because
the next time I look at it I i now am familiar
with this process and I say okay I created a scene
the scene is a description this is where he comes
home and it's miserable now I have to think okay
how do we see that he's miserable ask a question
he sees we see he's miserable because he takes his
little dinner out of the refrigerator
and throws it on the wall you know
each thing that you get when you ask a question
to me it's always a process of questions
and a process of writing down the answer
now I have a scene where a guy comes in
opens his fridge throws his dinner against
the wall okay we know he's miserable
now I can add a couple of lines move on to the
next scene everything that you can do to put a
little something down to create a bit of something
for your creativity to hang on to that's for me
the essence of the writing process so if this
were a movie then it would show glenn as a temp
and you know all right charlie have a good
weekend and then you had like a half hour
and then the music played and you realize wow
this is it and I'm I hear I am writing it and
and you're saying I actually think what we would
do in that case is we would show that we would
cut to the see the imaginary scene we would
play it out and and so we would get to catch
the the thrill of the creation by seeing the
created magic of this character in the scene
oh so yeah sorry I'm writing that no I love it
I love it so then so glenn is the as I'm writing
the writing then we you know cut to or dissolve to
by the way that's a little thing most of the time
hey don't write cut to william goldman started it
it's a delightful thing in his scripts obviously
they're going to cut too how else are they
going to get there you're wasting page space
don't say cut to and most of the time don't
say dissolve to or fade out or anything else
because that's their decision they'll unless
it's really important that you dissolve
just write the next scene and they'll figure
out how to get there anyway yeah get to the
glenn's writing and then show that scene where
the character is running to the phone booth in
the rain and it's a great scene and people will
get so excited by my creativity as a character
that they'll want to know what happens next you
say the writing process is about tools and skills
not theory but let's let's go with theory for
one moment so what theories are stopping a writer
before they even start that's actually a really
good question because I believe that the theories
are tools I believe that the the all the rules
I'm not saying there are no rules there are
plenty of rules there are a lot of rules what they
are not is a single set of rules that always works
and so what you need to do is know every possible
theory you can cram into your head you should
watch all sorts of different types of stories you
should watch outside in genres outside of the ones
you like you should specifically try to watch
things that are things you don't think you'd be
interested in and you should definitely try to
read those screenwriting books or or listen to
screenwriting teachers who are teaching very
very different ideas because there are so
many out there now and the answer is each one of
them will have very valuable parts very valuable
tools that you can use and the only thing that you
need to have is a really big toolbox as big as you
can get with every possible theory so that when
you're approaching your work which is really what
it's always going to be about you can say I have
seen a story like this or I have seen a story like
this but this other story had a different form
for it or this person said I should always have
my transitions in the middle of the story or this
one said I should always have a conflict at the
end of the story there's so many theories none of
them is wrong they're all right they're all there
to be used in different circumstances depending on
what you're trying to accomplish so the more that
you can learn all the different theories and all
the different paradigms and and story archetypes
that's all good but nothing will help until you
actually sit down and say I am making the choice
to write this particular story and this story
needs this set of rules maybe another story
needs another set maybe I need to pick one rule
from this one and one rule from that one maybe
my you know somebody says you know save the cat I
happen to believe that there are certain parts of
save the cat the book very valuable other parts I
can't make head or tail of and I don't think that
you should not read it I think you should read it
and take the pieces that you need I'm not sure you
should always save the cat but it's good to know
that saving the cat is a thing you can do and I
believe that that goes for every screenwriting
theory out there and the best thing that you
can do is know all of them so that you can say
hmm in this one is this type of character best
revealed by saving a cat or is this one somebody
who's gonna walk away and leave the cat there and
now we know a different thing about them how do we
still like them so really the most important thing
is to take whatever these rules are and apply them
to your particular goals because that's the thing
not every story has the same goals some are trying
to amuse you some are trying to scare you some are
trying to make you think they're going to have
very different ways of approaching storytelling
the important thing is that you have
as many tools as you can as many skills
you know how to make something funny if you need
to or how to make somebody like a character by
the way my theory on liking a character is the
way that we like a character is that we know
what they want I believe we can really get with
a character who wants something horrible they're
not saving any cats they're murderers or they're
trying to take over the world and we can still
really care about them because we are understand
that they want this thing for their reason
and very often that's something that we can care
about even though we don't honestly want them to
kill all those people but we get engaged in the
story and we follow the characters because we know
what they want my theory so if we don't
know what they what they want then somehow
do we not trust the character I personally
think we just don't think of them as a character
I think if you if you start to pay attention
to how you watch characters I think you'll
find out that you're always thinking what
do they want what are they trying to do
there'll be some form of that you don't just want
to watch someone say oh they have nice clothes I
mean you'll watch that for a few minutes but after
a while that person in the cool outfit had better
be trying to do something and people don't try
to do something if they don't want something
because it takes effort to do stuff and we
only do that when we have something we want
if we had that toolbox let's let's
say we put aside the save the cat
tool what's one of the most overused whether it's
good or bad tool one or two from this toolbox um
we're we're gonna pull it out and
make room for other stuff yeah um
i think the three-act structure it's
tricky there are there is a a world
where there's units of entertainment which
you watch in one dose call them features now
doesn't matter it could be a short but but
there's a type of story that you watch in one
dose and that does have a three-act structure in
the sense that it has a beginning middle and end
but the whole set of rules about turning points
happening at a certain point in a three-act
structure is simply an overused tool it came about
because movies were in movie theaters and that was
about as long as a person could sit in a movie
theater and also movie theaters wanted to sell a
certain number of tickets so they wanted movies to
be of a certain length a lot of this comes down to
business and honestly we shouldn't be making
our artistic decisions based on the fact that
movie theaters wanted to turn over the seats every
90 minutes now we have some stories that are not
three acts we have some stories that are 30 acts
we have some stories that are one act every story
though will have a beginning middle and end
so in a way the three act structure will apply
even an episode of a larger thing has a beginning
middle and end I think that's where the three act
thing came from because truthfully even in theater
they didn't always have three acts a lot of plays
before the 19th the 20th century had four acts
or five acts so three act save the cat possibly
doesn't mean they're bad or wrong but it's just
they're over they they're used a lot I'm saying
that you need to choose your form you need
to say I am going to watch a thousand stories
and I'm going to break some down I strongly
suggest that if there's something you like
watch it like five times watch it until you're not
enjoying it anymore so you can start to watch it
mechanically and say how do they do this and when
you do that stop like pause and write an outline
of the thing you're watching that you
like and learn how it's structured
and then do that with a bunch of other things
because you'll find out there's nothing consistent
the rules are all over the place and furthermore
a lot of these rules are like well you have your
inciting incident or your you know beginning twist
or whatever they everybody has names for them
none of that really matters because then you get
into an activity which is an academic activity of
find the part I'm going to name the inciting
incident what really matters is how the
audience feels as they're following the story the
audience is not looking for an inciting incident
they're not looking for a second act reversal they
don't care they care about the characters and if
you break down the things you love and reverse
engineer them and outline them you'll begin to
get a sense of how they do it how many beats does
it take before you are worn out of this thing how
long does it go before there's a twist or a turn
the only way you can really become skilled is by
breaking down the work and doing it yourself
you know you can study how to build a car
until the end of time but you need to
actually put together a car and make it
run and you probably have to do that a bunch
of times before you can make a really great car
how is being an artist very
different from being the audience
that is one of the hardest things to get used
to because we all begin as an audience there
I don't think there's an artist in the world
who didn't start by being a fan we all want to
do these things because we liked seeing them
absorbing them we were the best consumers and
the truth is the artist never experiences
their own work the way an audience will
because they first you know what's going to happen
you can't actually experience it you have to
reverse engineer that whole experience just like
if you were if you're building a roller coaster
you can't be riding the roller coaster at the same
time you have to actually say I need a support
here and I need a dip here and you're being very
mechanical and frankly artificial about it because
you're saying I want them to get a throw when they
go over that hoop hump and and in order to do that
I'm going to have to have this amount of force
up here and then it's going to have to have a
tailing out at that point and it's
going to become very mechanical
in order to give somebody else the
pleasure of riding that roller coaster
that's what you need to do as an artist is to say
I love the experience of going over that hump and
then zooming down and for some reason I don't
crash at the bottom that's because someone knew
how to get out of the free fall that I'm going
through the artist has to stop and learn the
mechanics how you support the track that's going
to do that how you make the story twist and turn
and provoke those experiences that you yourself
will never have and when you're actually doing
it you get this weird kind of duality because as
you're creating you usually have like a little
tiny bit of an audience's experience you'll
be like I'm actually enjoying the line I just
thought of as an audience did you'll have that
for a fraction of a second while you're doing
it and then after that you have to figure
out the mechanics to make that scene work
so you're constantly going back and forth sort
of saying I want to be an audience now and now
in order to get that audience I got to go back and
become the mechanic and you're constantly cycling
through them you can never really give up being
an audience but you have to also become the person
building the ride the other thing about artists
and audiences is that from the finished product
you can never tell how it got made one of the
things I think artists really should do is try
to read or hear podcasts or books about how things
you love got made because you'll always be amazed
at how the people who set out to do it did not
know that the final result was going to be what
we now think of as inevitable and the the stories
are actually I just read one about midnight cowboy
and and when they brought the book midnight
cowboy john schlesinger the director and the
producer brought the book to mgm the studio and
they said we want to do this very dark story about
this wannabe hustler going to times square and
mgm said we think this could be an elvis presley
vehicle and we're going to put in some songs and
we'll take out that dark stuff so you know on a
bad day mgm could have taken it over and it could
have been elvis presley in midnight cowboy which
would have been something to see but the point is
when we watch midnight cowboy it never occurs to
us how many different things had to go right
or had to be learned to make that happen
and having worked behind the scenes having created
things I can tell you that there are things that
I did not know going in somebody brought it to
me sometimes whole story ideas were not my idea
in fact the script I'm best known for fracture
wasn't my original script someone else had
written a very very good script the studio wanted
to make changes someone else was hired after that
then I was brought in so many of the plot twists
I didn't come up with I did a lot of the writing
that made those plot twists work in that form that
it did end up in but when you watch that movie you
come to me and say how did you think of that plot
twist the answer is I read it in somebody else's
script and I used it because that's the job
so the answer is you can't just look at stuff
you love and go ooh I know how they did that
you'll never know how they did that and you'll
never know how your work is going to come out you
just don't you have to get used to the experience
of trying to get something done doing the best
you can and seeing how it plays had talked about
something in the artistic process abstract to
concrete to abstract yes what is that that's
sort of a follow-up of the artist artist audience
issue which is you nothing will ever come out like
it feels to you that is part of the art I don't I
don't think there's any artist who hasn't gotten
hopefully used to it because it's part of learning
how to do it one of the things that brought this
to me was I was once looking at a picasso drawing
and late picasa drawings especially are just like
they're like scribbles you know it's it looks
sort of like a bull but how did he know to make
the line go like how did he know to do that
because it's just a scribble but it's a bull
and I suddenly realized he didn't know he knew
that whatever came out would be interesting he
trusted that and that's what every artist has to
learn that you don't know exactly how it's going
to come out you can outline I outline incredibly
thoroughly and I think I know what's going to
happen but the truth is that there's going to
be a process after that the creative process
good word for it you're creating something out
of nothing and when that happens it's going to
be something that you're going to discover as you
do it and then you need to shape it and rework it
and do all the other things that artists have
to do but the thing in your head there's this
feeling or this idea or this line and then you put
it on the page and then somebody else performs it
and then someone else sees it and in all of those
steps it's not what you thought it was going to be
and the best thing an artist can do is get really
comfortable in a sense getting comfortable with
a failure you're going to fail to get your
exact feeling and thought out to someone else
that's that's life it will never ever happen
that someone gets exactly what you thought it
was but what will happen is you'll get used to
doing that scribble and someone will go oh cool
ball and that's art that's the magic of it is that
you get used to bringing something abstract into
a concrete form and someone else gets an abstract
experience out of it that's that's something that
only art does it's beautiful so get used to sounds
like just experimenting and and trusting that I
may not know where it's going but this kind of
feels right and knowing that that same thing you
could see it could be changed drastically and
you have to be collaborative and okay with that
get used to the process get used to the
experience of doing the thing over and
over if you're playing tennis you get used to
hitting the ball and you hit it over and over
and then eventually you'll get to where you can
control it more but still there's going to be a
lot of other elements and what only thing that you
can get used to is the process of making the swing
likewise the process of thinking of something
writing it in a concrete form editing it
shaping it rewriting it giving it to other people
that process that's what you have to practice
that's what you have to get to enjoy and feel
comfort in and the more that you do it the more
that you'll get lucky and things will work out
and you'll be like oh I think this line is funny
and then you write it down and someone reads it
and they they laugh that gives you so much power
for the next time you do it because sometimes it's
going to work and sometimes it's going to not work
but the more you do it the more it will work
two kinds of writing creating and shaping
there are two kinds of writing and every piece
of writing uses both kinds it's not like somebody
only does creating and somebody only does the
shaping every writer has to get used to sort of a
over and over again process creating what
I call creating and it's just the the stuff
that comes out what some people call the
vomit draft or the the experience of just
trying to imagine stuff and write down what
you think trying to put yourself in a scene
or think what would they say next and write
it down you're accessing something that truly
humanity has no idea what it is or where it comes
from I don't know if it's something that other
creatures have but people have this weird ability
to make stuff up it's essentially dreaming you you
think of a story or a character or a moment or
a scene or a line and you don't you can't really
say where it comes from and this is every artist
in history has experience has described the same
experience of I was trying to write this thing and
this line just came to me this scene this twist
whatever it is it just comes to you and the more
that you can get used to the need to let it happen
however it happens to create without any judgment
at all without any criticism without any fear
saying anything that comes out of me at this
moment is fine and to be able to sustain that
and do that for a bit of time and get something
down and to get used to the experience of
making that written down feeling free with the
words even if they're bad even if if you're
bad at typing they're going to be misspelled
doesn't matter what matters is that they you
grab them from that mysterious place and you
get them on the paper that's creating but then
almost always it's going to need some shaping
some editing some rethinking writing rewriting
and that second shaping part is where you say
clean up all the typos break that long sentence
into two short ones make those two short ones
into one long one that word there that's really
vague what do I mean when I say baffled baffle is
actually pretty specific but you know what I mean
that do you start to think the way someone who's
not you would read it and whether they would get
the experience you're trying to give them and
then you start to be mechanical about it there's
tricks you can use putting the punch line at
the end putting the set up at the beginning
finding funny sounding words for funny lines
there's all these tricks of the trade that
goes in the shaping part when you're shaping
you're spending a lot of time being critical
and trying to when you're critical what you're
trying to do is I like to think of critical
as making the best of not saying bad I'm not
critical of it I am wow there's a funny bit in
that but this is getting in the way so critically
I'm going to get rid of the stuff that's in the
way of the good I like the good what's important
about being critical is that you're doing it to
improve what it is trying to be not make it into
something else and certainly not just slam it down
the editing part of you the rewriting part of
you is the second part of the process usually
it goes back and forth several times sometimes you
get weirdly creative while you're editing a new
line comes to you and then you so you're sort of
doing a micro switch editing editing oh new line
creative oh back to editing and that process goes
over and over most writers I know they tend to set
aside a separate mood you know I know I'm going
to have to do seven days of creating creating
craving I'm never gonna look back at what I wrote
and I'm just gonna every day set aside an hour
throw it down and then go you know make myself
a nice lunch then for another seven days
I'm going to look at what I wrote take a big deep
breath start to break it down start to do the work
stretch a little go back to it and that
process over and over will make for
great writing do you think too many writers
are focused on positive feedback instead of
writing something that can actually be made
that's interesting actually I do think that
we have developed a script reading industry within
the industry and that has sort of become a kind of
I don't know what the term is for like if you've
got a river and it suddenly gets like a little
backwater and things get stuck in there instead
of going with the flow but that's there is that
people who are writing scripts are unfortunately
mostly writing them to be judged by people whose
jobs is to read them that could be professional
script readers and critics it can also be anyone
who is an executive or a producer their job is
to read a script and try and figure out if that
script is going to be producible but still they're
they're working on the script many many people who
are in those fields don't know anything about
production they don't know anything about making
a movie and in fact when I say movie I mean
movie or show or filmed entertainment of any kind
the most important thing for a screenwriter
because it's a particular kind of writer
is that you are writing for production there is
no value to your writing until it is produced
someone may pay you money which is value in the
sense that they think it's going to get produced
but truthfully the value is if that script can
be acted and directed and edited and released
and there's different qualities which
are valuable to the people doing the
acting directing editing than the readers
and you need to be able to please both
because you can't get to the production
people without going through the readers
so I would say you need to learn
all the advice about how to please
a reader and what they're looking for
and what they the rules they have and
everybody tells you different rules
but know as many rules as you can
but still it's very important to understand
what happens when a script gets made if you can
make it yourself write a script for the purpose
of making it yourself just so that you learn
what happens when an actor has to say the lines
one of the things that happens is you'll learn
most of the lines that you wrote were probably
information in other words you were thinking
I need the audience to know this thing so I'll
write a line where somebody says it in some way
but what the actor and the director and the editor
need is for the character to need to say something
totally different the character has to need to say
the information if they don't need to say it it's
not going to work for the actor and the director
the only way that you can learn that is by having
actors and directors work with your script if you
are a diy type of person try it find a way to you
know at this point you can do it on your phone
you can get a bunch of actors from the nearby
community theater or college write something
that's appropriate to their ability of talent
and try it out it's going to take you some time
it's going to be some heartache there's going
to be some arguments but you will learn how your
script is transformed by the production process
what works and doesn't work and that is incredibly
valuable to everyone who eventually will make the
movie and if you can learn that stuff by and
you can pretty much only learn it by doing it
then you will be a screenwriter who's making
something not just to get approval but to actually
get made and be good so by running these lines by
these actors and filming it with your phone you're
finding out what's filler in the dialogue and
what is an actor or character wanting something
portraying that to another character who also
wants something what it really will come down
to is you'll learn what dramatic action is because
dialogue is action when somebody speaks actually
in real life too you're trying to do something
like when you go to a counter and say may I have
a pack of cigarettes well don't say that say say
may I have a club soda and a lottery ticket yeah
when you say that it's because you're trying to
accomplish something when you say to someone I
love you or I don't love you anymore it's because
you're trying to accomplish something you're
trying to make something happen or get something
you're trying to change your relationship with
them you're trying to get something some of
them to do something all dialogue should be
action that's what an actor needs to play and
that's what a director needs to direct is that
almost every writer you'll meet especially the
ones who have not been in production will think
in terms of information this dialogue is conveying
this information and they can make it sound nice
but if it's not actually action if the character
is not trying to change something in that moment
it's not going to play by the way the other
thing I wanted to say was I'm a fan of diy and I
think that we should demystify it the point of diy
filmmaking is mostly not to get your big break and
to have it sell for a billion dollars it's to get
experience it's the it's the same thing that the
the 10 000 hours you know malcolm gladwell in oh
gosh I can't remember the name of the book now
malcolm gladwell publicized this phrase
outliers is malcolm gladwell's outliers
ten thousand hours is what it takes to be a real
mastery of any particular thing you're doing
it took me like thirty thousand because
I'm really stubborn and slow but
that process for a screenwriter
has to include the production and
what happened was the the indie industry blew
up in the the 80s and 90s over somebody makes
a 3 000 movie and it sells a billion dollars
and and they're great for the rest of their
career and so everyone started making movies
for that aim for every one of those that was
huge there were thousands that lost all their
money and the important thing to know about diy is
you're going to lose all your money the you might
as well grab a lottery ticket to try and make
money off of indie filmmaking but that's not the
point the point is to do the work and get it to
an audience to get in production and if you don't
feel like diying yourself there are people who are
wanting to diy who can't write and they will love
you if you just want to write and give it to them
so the important thing about that is the same
thing that the ten thousand hours taught the
beatles when they went to hamburg and they had to
play god knows eight hour sets every day for weeks
and weeks on end supposedly that's when they got
good the work they were doing was not necessarily
their best work but they were producing their work
and putting in front of an audience and doing it
again the next day that's the important thing that
screenwriters are not given the opportunity to do
you're not going to be given that
opportunity so you should take it yourself
do it a nice safe way like I said if you're
a writer and you don't feel like producing
find people out there they want good scripts when
you were attempt for those 12 years was there one
story that you really clung to of your own of your
own writing that you thought this is going to be
it or were you constantly working on new things
well I did have this one script that kept on
getting passed around and people liked for
those 10 years and eventually it did sell so
that that for those who out there yeah 10 years
it can still sell and frankly after that 10
years 10 years after that it was still being
shown and people were showing interest in it
so that's one of the important things that
you should remember when you write something
and you're thinking this will be my break it
might be your break in the sense that people
recognize your talent through it and they never
make that but it becomes quote a show script
that's a perfectly valuable thing I got a lot
of show scripts I thought they were going to
be big hits I thought they were going to make me a
fortune but they were just something that somebody
read and said wow you're a good writer why don't
you write this thing that I think will make money
that's still a valid reason to write
a script and the script still exists
you know somebody doesn't buy it it's not like it
gets burned somebody else later on might like it
I'm wondering if we can critique some dialogue
of a scene i've written the scene is set in
modern times and it takes place in a hr human
resources department where our protagonist is maya
she's a single mom in her mid-30s she works as
an administrative assistant she's not one for I
guess what you would call water cooler gossip
she's kind of you know head down works hard
some of the other employees don't like her
but she she kind of tunes it out the other
person in the scene is tommy and he's
a young hr professional in his mid-20s
he landed the job out of college and he's been
promoted as he's a diligent worker and committed
to seeing the company run smoothly so tommy has
sent maya an interoffice email and asked her to be
at his office he does not say why in the email and
so the scene takes place where maya is knocking on
the office door of tommy's which is a jar he's at
his computer so maya says hi tommy and she knocks
hey tommy sound effect it's cool yeah sorry
yeah that's fine and there's tommy typing
I don't actually have the typing sound oh
hey maya thanks for stopping by have a seat
please maya sits down in the office chair facing
tommy's desk her body language is a bit tense
tommy speaks so and he quickly gets up
from his chair and shuts the office door
okay maya thanks again for being here
listen tommy pauses to reflect miley
leans in everything good there's a little bit of
an inflection in her voice which indicates worry
tommy clears his throat and breathes in maya
as you know our company policy states that all
employees electronic communications are monitored
from time to time so that human resources can be
certain that said employees are in accordance with
company rules and regulations my response okay
tommy from october 25th maya to january 25th our
it department noted that within this span of time
you had spent an excessive amount of time on
non-work-related websites during your agreed
upon hours of employment with us using a company
computer which is located at your desk and maya
interrupts tommy wait what what are you talking
about tommy raises his voice slightly louder
as you may remember maya from the company handbook
that was given to you on your first day of
employment with us which you signed all computer
time within an employee's work hours should be
strictly work related it was noted and he pulls
out his little handy-dandy pen clicking it
it was noted that you visited the following
websites on these dates and he turns around
a piece of paper that's printed and denotes with
his pen each incident maya looks at the paper in
disbelief and she sees on the paper a time stamp
a url of the alleged website the make model and
operating system of her work computer scanning the
paper and shaking her head she kind of exclaims
I don't even have an account on the social
media site and i've never been to this blog I
don't know what this is tommy exhales and pauses
therefore maya in violation of company policy
we're really sorry but we're going to have to let
you go maya responds okay wait stop I noticed the
other day there was a login page to my computer
and the username was someone else's I don't go to
these websites I don't even go to these websites
on my off hours so what are you talking about gets
defensive tommy interrupting my your check has
been prepared we will pay you through 5 p.m today
we will need your access card and the key to your
desk before giving you this final check are you
able to provide these two items for us today and
so that's the dialogue you want me to work yeah
please okay let's do that okay cool by the way
fun yeah the first thing i'd say is we don't have
to worry about the dialogue yet okay the first
thing you have to ask is what is the scene about
because the person is doing all the talking
is tommy but in fact it seems to me like the
scene is going to really be about maya that the
point of the scene is that maya's getting fired
the other point about scene is that she's getting
fired unfairly so one of the most important things
you have to do with each scene is say what is
this actually about dramatically what is the
center of the scene the center of the scene is
maya's getting fired unfairly now I would need
to know the rest of the story to really work
it because the truth is if maya's getting fired
unfairly and she is going to go out and get a much
better job in a career that she really loves like
a paragliding teacher then this scene would
first of all be much shorter because we don't
really care why she got fired unfairly so you'd
want to just get right to it in fact you know
most of the dialogue would go but if the scene
is about how she's going to now try and find out
who did it and therefore it's going to get into
a thriller we would need to get those details
into the dialogue because right now there isn't
actually enough specifics in tommy's accusation
so the first thing you need to do is decide
what the scene is about is it about maya being
motivated to investigate maya being motivated
to change her life so we're talking about a
bigger question which is what's your story about
the scene is part of the story you have to know
what the story is about then you can know what the
scene is about the scene is always about an action
currently the only person taking an action in that
scene is tommy maya doesn't do anything except sit
down and so one of the things I would say is if
it's maya's story which seems like it was from
the content of the scene you would want to give
her some action it could be begging it could be
insisting that she'd be given a hearing it could
be trying to explain it it could be turning on
tommy and saying why he thinks he's really doing
it there's a lot of possible scenes which give
maya an important action because really what we
want to know is what's maya going to come out
of this it could be that maya's crushed and it's
going to we're going to see her be miserable for a
long time before she discovers paragliding teacher
so the the [ __ ] the dialogue it only matters
in the sense that it reflects what the character
is trying to accomplish and what we are trying to
tell in terms of story for the character so that's
the first thing is dialogue comes last the next
thing about the dialogue though I would say is you
can be a lot shorter you know when she walked in
just as a dialogue lesson I would say he comes and
says maya sit down and then he says names the the
websites and the type of website the specific
information would tell us a lot about what this
story is about assuming it is the investigation
or it's just he says you know I'm sit down
you know linens are us vacations unlimited
and whatever it is we're finding out about
the person who did log in and it's also just more
interesting dialogue he just starts reciting these
weird things or outrageous you know porn sites
or whatever it is terrorist sites she's going
to be like I don't understand like she is but
then she's going to say I saw freddie at my desk
or someone at my desk and you know that only
so and so has a key because they're my superior
whatever it is you're going to be explaining
the situation that sets up the rest of the scene
and the rest of the business terminology
that was in the scene should go unless
it is possible to make it a wonderfully
suspenseful scene in which tommy is just
blathering on with you know corporate double speak
and we're getting tenser and tenser about what's
he getting to but then you would build the scene
a little differently his speech would be more
tarantinoy in which he's playing little mind games
with her as he does it so it's not impossible it's
not like there's an only one way to write a scene
you can play this scene with that kind of long
speech from tommy but then tommy's got to have
a reason that he's doing it the actual corporate
liability not that important I can keep going but
I probably should stop there no I love it so I
think the first thing then I need to determine
what is it that's going to happen to maya from
this story what's the story then what's the scene
because the scene only exists within a story
and with the story it's always going
to be for me the same six questions
who is it about what do they
want why can't they get it
what do they do about that why doesn't that work
what is the end and if you think about in this
case it's like well who is it about it's about
maya or tommy or maybe it's about someone else
about somebody that you know takes maya's job and
this whole scene should just be maya you're fired
but let's assume the scene's about maya so who
is about maya what does she want does she want
to keep this job or does she want to get a better
life once you've made that what's the obstacle the
obstacle of keeping the job is she got fired
unfairly the obstacle of the new life is she
wasn't prepared for this she's broke what does
she do about that if each one if she wants the job
back she has to find out who did this or find out
what tommy's up to or she would take those actions
always asking what is the story about and the
story is going to be about a character wanting
something and so story is about she needs this
job she has this son and you know she's kind of
been left to pay a bunch of bills and money's
tight for her and she doesn't like this job but
she really needs it that's that's part of
the story I guess there has to be more of
what is going to happen to her life well then you
have to decide yeah in a big picture what story
do I want to tell do I want to tell the story
of someone who takes on the corporate bad guys
is it about someone who stumbles on a sinister
plot is it someone you know whatever kind of
story you want to tell is really going to make
that determination what kind of story do you like
if you like the sinister plot story or if you
like the she's going to team up with a whole
bunch of other people who are unfairly fired and
create their own company you know I mean there's
all sorts of it could start be the start of a
comedy or it could be the start of a thriller
right and so with the dialogue it should be much
more to the point don't worry about the corporate
double speak unless I was really going to do this
crazy sort of tarantino ask in theory less is more
on dialogue but not always some great long scenes
exist it just had better be worth it it better be
something that is creating some set piece moment
where something extraordinary is happening not
just a big turning point but we're getting a sense
of the style of these characters in this movie
that's going to be all about mind games or all
about taking down tommy because he's such an ass
right like glenn gary glenn ross exactly those
long scenes and and shows these salesmen and
kind of like what their style was and different
things right and so this is not that I don't
think that there are there's really any absolute
rule like keep dialogue short although in general
keep things short because we like to move along
but truthfully it's more a matter of finding the
model that you are trying to be like if you're
saying yes I want to have a really dialogue heavy
intricate character based drama then keeping it
short is not always to your advantage it depends
you just have to make certain choices everything
is a choice and every choice has a price you have
to decide what type of thing you're trying to
do make the choice to do that and then you build
every other thing based on those choices how many
times have you been hired by a hollywood studio
or producer where they did not require you to
outline for writing a script that's sort of
tricky because I would never not outline so
therefore whether they were required or not I was
going to do it the interesting thing is whether
or not they understood how much work an outline is
because the truth is very often in order to figure
out the solutions to a story to make the choices
of a story because that's really what
figuring out the solutions is is saying
it's going to be a story about this it's going
to be a story where this is the central action
that's the outlining process and that's very
very difficult that can take as harder work
than writing the script and so everyone is
always asking you to essentially do that work
before they decide whether
they're going to hire you
although things have changed a little bit but
truthfully most people assume that an outline
is very short and they did them in school so it's
not a big deal but an outline is really the main
work of screenwriting and it can take twice as
long as writing the script itself if you've got
a good outline you can write a script and it
will go pretty quickly figuring out all the
possible shapes and choices of an outline that's
brutally hard so the answer is I would never take
on a job that I hadn't at least roughly outlined
because I wouldn't know that I could solve it
do people ask you to do outlines for free yes
should you do it for free no it depends on where
you are in your career and what it's worth
to you if you want the experience of doing
the outline and you want to gain their trust but
don't do something you're going to regret for free
I think that would be my advice on
that the other thing is features
and shows are very different in shows the
outline breaking the story is a required step
for the company it's also usually not
done alone you don't usually send one
person off to do it although sometimes you do
depends on the showrunner but outlining a show
is part of the literally part of the job like you
go into the room you start by breaking the story
so nobody would ask you to do that without
being paid because you're already on the job
do you have a proven style of outlining that
has worked for you the most it's proven to me
in the sense that yeah I think it's great i've
done a if you check out my videos there's one
called why outline and one called how to
outline the how-to has the outline system
but basically what it really comes down to is
the important thing is to think in scenes and
write a a a written version where you are writing
down the scenes in a list that's what an outline
is an outline is a list of scenes some people
can do it on index cards they even have index
card software where you can put a lot on it I
believe that the important thing is to understand
that you are breaking a story into scenes and
then when you have your full list of scenes
and you know what everything is going to happen
in every scene and there's nothing missing then
you're ready to write so that's the importance
of an outline the actual form of it it's whatever
works for you I believe that the most important
thing the thing to put in that first line the
the the headline of each outline step is not where
it takes place or even what happens it's what is
the essential action the point of the scene so
the point of this like we were talking before
about a scene where maya gets fired the point
of that scene is that maya gets unfairly fired
you try to make things active always try to
put things in active form so maya gets fired is
actually passive she's getting fired the scene
actually is tommy fires maya unfairly now for
me that's a scene line because I know exactly
what the action is and I try to always break it
down to that sometimes you know I'm the only one
looking at it oh that's the other thing outlines
should be for you outlines are not to be read by
other people it's a workspace it's a workplace
if you have to do an outline for another person
that's a performance you should copy your outline
and then write a version for other people to
read but but for you to work in an outline the
important thing is that you're doing whatever will
trigger you to understand the point of the scene
sometimes I know a scene so well that I'll just
write joe drives to dallas now I know that during
the course of that he has to have a breakdown but
doesn't matter I know what that means but really
the scene is joe has a breakdown while driving to
dallas the important thing is the central action
of the scene and while there may be many steps
in any scene there's usually one thing more than
anything else that that scene is about and that's
the point of the outline then for me underneath it
I'll put everything I can think of I'll write
dialogue in my outline I'll do whatever I can
because I can always just cut and paste it out
later but that space under the headline is where
you can ask yourself questions you can and I
write them in a different color I write why is
joe having a breakdown how do we know that joe
is having a breakdown and then I'll answer it
and I'll describe maybe I'll say like he crumples
up his hamburger and smashes it into the rearview
mirror whatever it is I'm trying to get everything
I can into the outline so that I will know what
it is when I write the scene those outline
descriptions can be very long they can be
arguments with myself the most important thing
to do though is break everything into a scene
there's nothing that is going to go into your
script that isn't in a scene so the whole point
of an outline is to get you to remember if
I don't have a scene where that happens if
I don't have a scene where that subject is raised
or that feeling occurs it's not going to be in the
story how common is it for you to write backwards
I always believe everyone should write backwards
but by that I do not mean you actually start in
the last scene and write it right backwards I mean
know the ending that's really what right backwards
means right backwards is a crucial thing because
until you know the ending you don't actually
know what your story is about for instance if
if you're telling a story in which someone
is trying to save their sister from lions
then whether or not they actually do save
their sister and how they do it do they do
it by overcoming their fear of lions or
do they do it by learning lion language
and telling the lions to stop that's going to be
what the story is about until you know that last
thing the thing that resolves the tension you
don't really know how to write anything else so
work backwards really means know your ending once
you know the ending everything else makes sense
in a different way because you know that it's
an obstacle towards that or a step towards that
when you were asked to take out that core part of
the one script did you go back to your outline and
you saw it there I don't know if it was like
the midpoint or where it was and then try to
reiterate like how did when you went to that
what was your reaction to seeing that actually
I i totally failed on the first time I had to
do this so I'll tell you about the second time
when I succeeded at it but the important thing
is if you're taking out the core of a story
if you're talking about the essential center of
the story it's not going to be in one place the
horrible thing the reason that you can't do it is
because it's in every scene and that every single
action the person's taking is about a thing and
if they say let's not do that thing then you're
really in trouble because you have to rewrite
everything and worse than rewrite everything
you don't have any reason to do the other thing so
you don't just tear it out you have to replace it
I was working on a thriller it was about a
schizophrenic woman living in new york she
had just been released from a mental hospital
and she's living in a crappy poor apartment
in hell's kitchen and the woman next door to
her is having an affair with a police officer
a street cop and the they have an argument the the
lovers have an argument and during the argument
they the woman grabs the cops gun it goes off and
while he's trying to get it back and he kills her
the schizophrenic woman hears
all this through the wall
and tries to leave and when she does the
cop sees her and the rest of the thriller is
what's going to happen about that I was in a very
ornate 1970s character-based kind of frame of mind
so not only did I add that but I added two more
characters one was an evil sergeant who was trying
to force the cop who was actually not a bad guy
to kill the witness so the villain is actually
the murderer's boss the woman who has the
witness has nowhere to go no no one's gonna
listen to her she's schizophrenic she says
she heard something to the wall what you know
so the one person that she had to turn to in my
first draft of the story was a guy who was an
orderly in the hospital where she was and he was
very kind to her and she finds him and she tells
him what happened she asked for his help that was
a very ornate complex set of relationships and
jody foster's company loved it but it was
difficult and they god bless them they
gave me a lot of money and a lot of time
and they worked with me and we worked
on it trying to figure out how to make it a
little more acceptable to the studio system
and the executive there was meglifoe who
is now a phenomenal teacher and writer and
we worked on it and she never asked the thing that
I knew we needed but she never said could we cut
one of these four characters you've got a thriller
with four main characters and I eventually said
I think there's a way to get rid of the guy
that the mentally ill person goes to now that
was taking out the core of the story because
by the end of the story they have teamed up to
defeat the evil sergeant and so I was removing the
center of the story and I had been asked before in
other jobs to remove the center of the story and
it just ruined my life so in this case I thought
you know I asked the essential question what
is this story about and the story was about
this woman who knew that she had heard a real
thing but because of her disability people were
not taking her seriously and the people who were
taking her seriously were trying to kill her right
she's the center of the story and I had divided
her action among two people I thought that was
cool as a writing exercise it is cool as a movie
for jody foster it's not cool it was a dumb choice
but on the other hand when I wrote it jody foster
wasn't going to do it so once I moved into that
position I thought you know what this woman's
character needs to hold the whole story on herself
and the relationship really is about her and the
poor policemen in between her and the villain
so from a four-way story I made it a three-way
story it was better it was a better version now
I had worked really hard on the four-way version
and I loved it and I was very proud of myself
for recognizing that there are even with
something that is like I think it's great
the original version but it's not the only way to
do it and that was a real breakthrough for me to
recognize that something that I loved and felt
right also had another version that I loved and
eventually felt was even more right the triangle
version was much more powerful and the characters
became much more interesting so how do you do it
you look at what is the real center of the story
the center of the story was this woman that
because of her disability had very limited
ability to defend herself or get help and how she
found the resources of communicating with people
to solve that problem did the film ever get made
with another last no it didn't and they tried they
tried so hard they were wonderful they they did
but it was just a really hard project at a really
hard time and there's a lot of times when
something you don't get all the pieces together
and if you follow the trades you'll often see
this happening where a passion project for someone
but it requires to get the right alignment of
stars and financing and all these other things
have to come together and everyone has to believe
in it for all their own reasons it's a frankly a
astonishing that anything gets made at all I would
watch that movie me too yeah yeah that's well it's
that's powerful but but the answer is how do you
remove the center of your story and the answer is
you look for where it is in the story and you'll
usually find it's it's not where you're the
thing you're clinging to because the thing you're
clinging to is clearly making people uncomfortable
and if enough people are telling you something
is not working for them you have to come to
a choosing point you have to say I want it to
work for me and I don't care about anybody else
but if enough if a lot of people are saying I
really love this but it's not working in this
way you have to think about is there something
about that that you can rethink the other thing
is sometimes you have to remove the heart of
your story and then you better just replace it
find a new heart find a new core to the
story that works well and the story will
keep living wow that was like so metaphorically
well-turned yeah with with this story was was the
schizophrenic woman was it her journey out of the
hospital into quote normalized life or was it also
getting people to regard her as that was actually
one of the big problems was it was very important
to me to fairly portray what often is not
shown in movies most movies are like well
if they could just get sympathy they'd be cured
and the reality of her illness was that she was
not going to get all over it with an insight she
had a serious mental illness and the question was
how can she communicate and gain others trust
and learn to trust them in order to get help
and so one of the hardest things was essentially
a lot of people wanted it to become a story about
someone who's a neglected action hero and and
that's not what what the company wanted you know
they really respected the point of the script and
certainly not what I intended I wanted to try and
talk about what it's like to have a
mental illness and need to work with it.
What did you like about this video?